nail art is gorgeous but I am terrified
of this challenge I'm gonna kill this
and I will become an Internet Pinterest
sensation overnight most of these
designs are way more complicated than
anyone should have on their nail it
looks so easy it's just painting your
nails this base coat is so important
because if it's not just really pretty
then you can't paint over it well Oh God
oh there's a brush inside a lot wetter
then I was expecting I'm doing my best
to not get it on my fingers my best
isn't good enough makes a nice sound
I'm finger nail Picasso it's like a
horrible wax museum right now this is
something that would be nice to do with
a glass of wine and some music this I
might be able to do because it's like a
straight line I guess I'm just going to
glob it on and see if it dries er it's
hard to like get enough but also not get
too much looks kind of like a blob until
my finger dance for me whoa it got
everywhere oh no there's zero margin for
error here I really have no idea what
I'm doing
Oh God let that dry it's gonna look like
a huge bead okay not too bad it's a good
thing like if I was actually doing this
I would be like think I finished up this
hand and looked over and I would have
liked up my other hand completely yeah I
think all hopes were they getting the
design right I've gone out the window
like three layers again I think that's
as close as I can get hey we'll what are
you doing after the gym some mother nail
art we're gonna try to do the leaf marks
with this just like blobby
you know it at first this was like funny
I was like haha I'm gonna paint my nails
and now I really care and this is kind
of frustrating it doesn't look
deliberate someone came up to me she
would just be like oh not even like
congratulations for even trying it's too
easy I'm doing it now it looks like
there's a butt cheek on my hand I'm far
too fresh for black stripes I'm gonna go
in neon
pink stripes I knew I was gonna be crap
at it I didn't realize how crap I'd be
do I like them I don't know and the
stripes are just like why did I go why
did I go bright pink I think I should
probably go back and learn how to draw
it in the lines again mother had got
some nail art of its own and I feel like
I was very careful I thought I was a
creative person but I just don't have
the dexterity in my hands to make
something beautiful on the tiny canvas
that is your fingernail I tried I feel
like I'm supposed to be holding
something but I'm painting my own hand